what's going on everybody welcome to
part 5 of our robotics with the
Raspberry Pi tutorial video series in
this part we're going to be talking
about how we can control that USB cannon
now if you don't have the cannon you
want to get one I'll put a link to it in
the description so you can check that
out otherwise let's get to it
so first of all there is some sample
code that came with the go p-- i go to
work with the cannon you'll need that
you would need a USB mouse connected to
the go PI or the Raspberry Pi itself in
order to make it work but instead I'd
like to do this and be able to control
that cannon remotely and then eventually
we we just want to be able to get
comfortable with it so that we can write
code and logic that can control this
cannon all on its own so first of all
let's check out the code that that came
from go PI go basically so we can go to
home slash PI and then going to go PI go
software Python examples and then we're
looking for the office cannon so we'll
double click there and here's office
cannon v1 PI let's go ahead and open
that up and in here we can see that
we've got all these imports most of
these basically all of these you should
have besides the USB stuff so just for
the record I think if you get this from
if you get the card from go PI go you
will already have PI USB otherwise
you're gonna want to come over here and
if you haven't already done sudo apt-get
update update and then go ahead and do
sudo apt-get install python - pip and
then once you've done that and you have
a pip do pip install PI USB install all
that and you should be all set so now we
have the code here and what we're gonna
go ahead and do is basically we'll take
this and copy that and then come all the
way down here and we'll at least copy
down to here we'll copy that let me
set this aside for now actually we might
have to recopy that but go over to home
slash PI desktop go PI go local and I'm
gonna go ahead and right-click here
duplicate and I'm going to duplicate
this to tutorial five dot pi and then
I'm gonna open that up and then we've
got our key input here
I'm gonna do enter enter just a few
enters here and let's come back over to
the original script here from office
Canon right click copy and then we'll
just paste all that in there now control
we don't really need but we're gonna
leave that there for now and then coming
down here we can see there's some basic
code here and this is we basically want
all of this for sure so we'll take that
and we're gonna go ahead and copy that
starting code and we're gonna come over
here above the command stuff and we'll
paste and then highlight that block of
code and then do control open square
brackets two times get that to come on
over now we have the basic set up here
trying to think of anything will cause
problems I believe probably the only
thing that'll cause us trouble at the
moment is gonna be maybe time delay but
we should be all set so I'm gonna go
ahead and move this over and now what we
want to do is we want to add controls
for the actual four key input here so
we've got all this stuff here this is to
control the PI but now we've got this
stuff for the missile launcher so now we
want to add in some controls for the
missiles so let me make the size a
little bigger and I'm gonna pull this up
and so we're within the key input
function so coming on down after our
definition basically of the let me do
this of what we're gonna do with the
servo let's make some space
and what we're gonna add here is first
of all the fire so we're gonna ask will
use the control buttons for fire since
spaces occupy this stop so we're gonna
say L if key press double equals control
underscore R or key press equals control
underscore L if either of those is the
case then we want to we'll go ahead and
print fire rockets and just moving I'm
you don't have to bring yours over but
let me do a control f5 rockets there we
go
so to fire the Rockets just looking at
the code for the office cannon that we
took this is basically because we were
you can use your mouse to do it but
we're not going to worry about that so
the command to actually fire the Rockets
is run command fire and then T delay
which I'm not sure this we're prime not
gonna have that but we'll go ahead and
copy that come down here and then BAM
run command fire and then T delay so now
we're gonna check out run command and in
fact let's go ahead and let's global T
delay here and actually let's see where
is let's find the time delay anyway
figure out yeah so it's right here
let's go ahead and just actually let's
take this cut and let's just put that at
the very top of our script I'm just
gonna paste it here
okay so put time delay there if you if
you couldn't find it just search for T
delay and you'll just you're looking for
when it's actually defined so mines here
but you can find it and it'll actually
be in one of your functions there so
just take that and put it to the top
that way you can reference time delay in
the rest of your script so then coming
down here so that was to fire and we're
we're saying the fire is going to be
with one of your control keys now what
we want to do is actually be able to
control because the the missile launcher
itself is on as sort of turret
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
define all the controls for like moving
the turret around so for example we can
do that with our arrow keys so we're
gonna say L F key underscore press
equals left what we're gonna do is we'll
just print out left rockets and then we
do run underscore command and the
command we want to run is left for the
Rockets and then we want to delay it
with time delay okay and now we're going
to go ahead and copy that and paste it
three more times for the other controls
so copy paste paste paste so we've got
left right right and right and then
we're gonna have up up and then down
down and down so then these are all the
commands that will hopefully be able to
pass to our missile launcher with the on
the turret there so let's go ahead and
save that
so that's tutorial 5 and we'll bring
over our remote desktop here will open
up the terminal and let me make that
terminal full-size for everybody and
then we're going to navigate to where
we're writing the script which is CD
into desktop
I'm and go PI go local and you see
tutorial 5 so now sudo python tutorial 5
dot pi we'll go ahead and run that and
it takes a little bit to first set up
but you can see that it's running that
initial code there to move the turret at
least and we know it's set once this TK
went to window comes up so the reason
why I just moved just then is that
initial setup here so that sets up the
USB there we run this code and then we
run this command
ro and then a hundred there interesting
Skype is hacking me apparently so anyway
run command zero 100 and then we're
stopping and like waiting for more
commands so that's just that's bill
thing that was part of the go p-- i go
so we can literally check for zero here
right so run command zero basically all
this does is moves our cannon down into
the left by this much so just keep that
in mind now i'll save that but we should
be able to run now so well first we'll
check forward
okay stop backwards stop and now we can
test our arrow keys to hopefully move
our missile launcher left we'd already
moved all the way left so now we're
moving it right no problem we can move
it up down awesome move it around and
then now we're try control to actually
fire the cannon itself sure enough i
just shot myself awesome hit me right in
the back um alright so now we're able to
actually control our robot with our keys
and what's nice about that is now that
we can control it with our keys that
also means that we can actually start to
build Python logic to start to control
our go PI go and then eventually we can
make it fully autonomous and then we can
make it shoot stuff based on logic and
we don't even have to do anything so
hopefully you guys guys at that point
the USB missile launcher I think it's
just super cool I realize it was $45 but
the cool factor is just so high for me
and I love how you can move it up down
left and left and right and probably
what I'll end up doing is maybe even
taping or something the Raspberry Pi
camera module to the missile launcher to
actually see where we're gonna fire the
distance sensor we may leave it on but
it would also be nice to have the
distance sensor on the missile launcher
because then you can actually do the
calculation of how far is the target and
then we can kind of move the turret up
to account for you know
making that distance but that'd be
really complex we'll probably keep it a
little more simple than that we're
already gonna try to do image
recognition with OpenCV so we might
avoid doing that but anyway pretty cool
I love the little cannon I love that you
can like shoot it and it actually shoots
pretty far I mean this this will
actually get across my room if I fire
this I mean that goes all the way across
my room my room's not huge or anything
but pretty cool so anyways if you guys
have any questions or comments up to
this point please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and until next time oh and
I forgot to mention how I actually
mounted the missile launcher on there
really simple I just used some tape and
made it double-sided tape stuck it on
there and that works good enough so
anybody who's curious how I did that
that's literally all I did you could
glue it on there if you really wanted it
to stay but I didn't I just used
painters tape honestly and made a little
loop stuck it on there and that was more
than enough to keep that thing steady so
anyway figured people might be curious
how it actually got on there anyway till
next time